photo qui est montré qu'ils aient montré
à droite c'est vrai que c'est par
semblant du taux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne soirée de m6 a continué avec ici
on se rencontrer et d 23h38 on a le
droit à une belle réflexion
philosophique sur le romantisme
important alors c'est trop bien
ensuite à 20 35 m3 on a fait la
découverte de pierre un gars un peu
diffus découvert que julien n'est pas
comme sur les photos mais qui à peine
tenté un petit compliment
avec des yeux bleus c'est faux
[Musique]
giulia donc c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
l'émission on a vu sur les réseaux il ya
plein de gens qui ont dit que vous aviez
mis des filtres et que voilà il est est
ce que vous avez été choqué par la
tonalité des messages alors j'ai regardé
au début ouais parce que on a un gros
poids de sap avec les personnes qui ont
fait l'émission avec moi donc un groupe
où on rigole bien et c'est renvoyer
l'image c'est au travail ont déjà j'ai
vu l'image ces faits n'ont laissé tomber
ça va pas être possible ensuite je me
suis quand même renseigné j'ai regardé
un peu sur m6 etc et là je tombe des
nues parce que déjà je vois le début de
l'extrait jeu mais pas le son clairement
je suis pas allé jusqu'à la fin de
l'extrait je ne savais pas que mon image
à lettres entre kim et ernie comme ça
après je peux reconnaître que la
différence entre les photos qui sont
montrés à gauche et la photo qui est
montré qu'ils monteraient à droite c'est
vrai que c'est par semblant du tout
maintenant est ce que ça m'a vraiment
touché non parce que en fait je me
reconnais pas dans la personne qui est
qui à gauche
sans me vanter je me reconnais
clairement plus dans la personne à la
droite lui taux plein ouais même si
cette photo elle date de 2018 je me
reconnais clairement plus ont été
tournées quand ça moi d'accord [ __ ]
téléspectateurs étaient violents sur
twitter j'ai truc son prétendant été
violent pardon mais quand une fille vous
avez index bdi toi [ __ ] c'est chaud
c'est extrêmement vives y avoir cette
année voilà regardez
[Musique]
savoir le rythme ça fait bizarre de voir
et ça fait bizarre je m'étais imaginé
julian wilson kardashian donc c'est vrai
que je me sens en plus gênés c'est un
peu de leur mac c'est pas ma fille des
photos ça vous fait c'est la première
fois que je vois les images c'est pour
ça que
j'ai bientôt vous pouvez commencer c'est
drôle moi je trouve aussi c'est marrant
parce que voilà on a un bon feeling on
s'entend bien ouais c'est ça on se plaît
on s'entend bien voilà donc du coup du
coup
[Musique]
ne sont pas prises d'être en groupe
non tout est resté pas tout bas non
d'accord
la télé ça reste la télé jeu on est
d'accord que la réalité enfin vous voyez
en face c'est toujours ce que vous voyez
quand même que je peux mieux et plus
avec ma soeur je vous le confirme
combien ils vous font clairement passé
pour l'art n'accélérant que vous êtes
une arnaque vous êtes mieux rien hadji
siècle voilà l'arnaqué du siècle à lille
met en bio rasta voilà je pense qu'ils
mettent tous en scène parce qu'ils
veulent faire une émission agréable à
regarder ce qui est le cas mais il
oublie que ça peut être très violent
yakin presque un million de personnes
qui regardent et je pense que vous vous
êtes fait défoncer sur les réseaux et
c'est très injuste est ce que vous avez
le sentiment ils ont truqué déformer la
réalité ouais clairement oui après c'est
c'est le sait c'est le jeu est là j'ose
le dire devant vous parce que je les dis
aussi à la productrice de l'émission et
j'ai été transparente avec elle je lui
ai dit vous m'avez clairement créé des
complexes que je n'avais pas déjà je
dirais pas pourquoi il a dit au cul
temps après ça regarde m6 et c'est je
crois ce qu'on annonce à regarder m6
maintenance et c'est une très bonne
qualité
parce que justement grâce il ya du
positif
c'est pêchu ces jeunes cyril on m'a déjà
pas respectées essaye de me respecter au
dessus des places et je le change et
appelle travail respectant mieux parle
de ton ami en fin de vie parce que tu as
c'est pas beau la cbc radio [ __ ] je
dirais peut-être ses consignes
[Musique]
jarret étonné de me voir c'est normal on
se connaît pas qui conduit
c'est peut-être on s'est trompé il ya
erreur c'est pas c'est pas le bon
alors là donc elle attendait guy arrive
pas ce que c'est je rappelle le principe
des missions sept mois de relation
virtuelle et ensuite ils seront donc à
l'attendent lui parce que ça faisait
sept mois qu'ils parlaient ensemble
c'était vraiment important pour vous
étiez amoureuse de lui ben oui
j'aimerais te présenter mes excuses de
ne pas
avoir honoré le rendez vous
j'espère que tu comprendras je
t'embrasse
[Musique]
en fait
administrativement parlant
et qu'il est marié avec une femme depuis
quatre coups
entre l' empêche les trucs ça fait plus
d'un an un peu plus d'un an qu'ils sont
plus ensemble quoi ils sont séparés
chacun vit chez lui chacun a refait sa
vie
mais quand l'autre ça on est où là ils
se déplacent même pas pour me le dire
lui-même il envoie son aide on est sans
cesse voir tu envoies ton ami avec une
lettre mal écrite veut m expliquant que
tu es marié depuis quatre ans qu'est-ce
que je l'avais dit au sujet du mensonge
si la phrase est long tu me le dis je
vais la raccourcir non mais le mensonge
on en a parlé
réponse sinon ça va je te plaît
physiquement c'est bon
s'appelait marc gare doit partir
parce que qu'est ce que vous dites aux
gens qui disent que vous êtes une
comédienne et que tout ça c'est du fake
mais s'ils disent que je suis une
comédienne j'accepte si pour eux après
on peut me repérer 1,6 à jean dujardin
domaine qui donne tout ça y est
je sais pas il n'y a pas de souci
maintenant moi je vais dans une émission
telle que celle ci je sais très bien qu
elle va passer devant la france entière
le monde ils devront moi je dois aller
me ridiculiser voilà donc vous si vous
étiez vraiment vous aviez des sentiments
pour guy oui j'en ai toujours dit avec
guy
on en est là
où ça on est là ou là là bas je ne suis
pas dit un trader
cet ensemble ou pas ensemble c'est un
bien grand - c'est pour ça que je
préfère dire qu'on est là vous êtes non
et si vous êtes on voit si oui oui il
nous reste et vous le croyez locaux
questions et d'y et le reste ça veut
dire quoi leur espace pour avoir peur
des mots un beigne coucher non non
c'était prévu si tout s'était bien passé
on était censé passer le week-end ça il
m'a dit qu'hoarau on va aller faire un
week-end après cette vue machin match
auquel j'étais contente mais quand il
vous dit qu'il va divorcer que ces
filaments maria je suis pas connu mais
il est consommé par rapport à la
question il laisse ce qu'on appelle le
bénéfice du bhoutan sont peut considérer
que vous êtes en couple aujourd'hui même
si on n'avait pas fait un truc tu fais
quoi
lannoy mais faut-il pas s'il fait comme
j'ai dit là il parle pas
[Applaudissements]
je vous avais kent
non non non voilà donc vous êtes cons et
là que pas de faim des trucs
c'est toi
donc c'est un homme bon voilà quoi on
est là quoi qu'il
y avait c'était un bon feeling pote quoi
un pote bob les bruins rien mais tu
avais quand même envie de faire une un
truc avec l quoi oui à la base oui à la
base oui avec apple corps en vie et qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé c'est
possible tu as vu italien ben comme j tu
commandes d'une porsche turbo semaine du
goût
la villa
est ce que toi quand tu as vu tuân
il était conforme à ce que tu
t'attendais oui donc tu étais tu n'as
fait tu l'as bien aimé oui j'ai bien
aimé vous vouliez faire une usine il a
42 ans avancer l'histoire commencé un
homme voilà c'est ça et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé est bien le drame c'est à
dire
en fait il a m'a carrément fait de
l'umih nation en public quoi en plus je
te le dis et je le vois la boit
mais même si j'étais marche en fait dans
le volant mais je sais qu'ils n'ont en
effet pas non seulement sur ça c'est pas
un mais deux en plus ce n'est pas le cas
je te lire et envoyer des photos
filtré ok mais un jour je t'ai dis c'est
pas moi j'assume je mets des filtres
tiens je vais t'en vois une vidéo je
suis juste maquillée de trois secondes
ou je te fais un bisou comme ça c'est ça
la vidéo
oui et après des photos maquillé mais
sans filtre pourquoi tu es venu de quoi
je suis venu moyens pour péter vu le
second sera baptisé au togo avait donc
c'est pas mon visage c'est mon corps non
il n'ya pas que le sort c'est tout
l'ensemble c'est lanta jamais vu mon
corps est à vue et tu met il pas mettre
encore si je les ai vus quand tu es
parti sur le plateau octobre à la porte
j'ai vu le ton corps et à
l'investissement et à poser problème
c'est tout l'ensemble je suis très
physique spéciale donne le droit de
danger aucun droit comme je te dis
excuse moi si j'étais vexé ou pas mais
comme je dis d'avoir des opinions et
avant les goûts et les couleurs c'est ce
que je pense mais croire tu as carrément
attirer la banane
avec la ballade ça se fait pas ça se
fait pas non mais tu te rends compte un
peu moi tu as de la chance je suis forte
ouais mais une autre nana là tu peux la
détruire en deux aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que tu aurais à dire as-tu and back
texte un gros bâtard
il oublie de dire c'est que il ya eu
pire mais que m6 sa part voulu faire le
montage à cause du csa jeu m'a parlé de
vrai montage qu'est ce qui vous a dit il
ma part tu m'as parlé q c'était presque
de l'harcèlement sexuel non on revient
supérieur sera tu m'as tu veux que je te
dise comment il m'a dit toi tu as bien
de prendre des trucs dans le cul je me
dis ça
parce qu'ils aiment se rendent et
ruinant
curricula déjà à la base quand il te
dira alors s'il vous plaît ça on veut
pas ça c'est vraiment raison les images
et si je peux porter plainte je peux
récupérer les images pieds dans la merde
parce que là tu veux parler comme ça
avec
deux ans il n'y a pas d'âge pour parler
comme ça va bien sûr nation c'est un bon
alors je suis un gros lot l'acceptent le
problème
tu te rends pas compte de la violence
dit oui tu dis c'est bien mais comme il
ya une différence entre le penser le
dire à la personne et le dire à la
personne devant un million de personnes
et là on a envie d'un million
il ya des gens qui sont traumatisés par
ça et souvent c'est pas du tout contre
vous mais souvent les gens qui formule
des attaques gratuites et frontale sur
le physique tu as envie de leur dire
mais tu t'es vu toi jamais le nommer il
a mis la raison
tu as des gens pour le menu tv toi c'est
quoi un mauvais si tu dis moi qu'est ce
qui te vaut c'est pas contre vous et les
gens je te rassure
franchement si elle était comme les
filtres et tout ça
mais je la voyais comme ça je la voyais
pas comme ça c'est
à dire jamais et est révisée pour les
autres mettaient pas très physique pour
toi apparemment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]